[Música]
les doy la bienvenida a un nuevo
episodio de boleto de vuelta que hoy nos
lleva a la gran muralla verde el
proyecto ecológico en áfrica que se ha
vuelto una prioridad no sólo para el
continente sino para el mundo reverdecer
el sahara y el sahel crear una franja de
vegetación que atravesará el continente
africano desde dakar hasta guti con casi
8 mil kilómetros de longitud y 11 países
atravesados esa es la gran muralla verde
un proyecto que no se hace casi 20 años
que fue lanzado oficialmente por la
unión africana en 2007 para luchar
contra la desertificación desde entonces
la iniciativa ha evolucionado se ha
vuelto más social ideas no sólo
restaurar las tierras devoradas por el
desierto sino también crear millones de
empleos y generar un crecimiento verde
pero por el momento los avances han sido
mínimos 15 años después de su
lanzamiento sólo el 4 por ciento de los
objetivos se ha cumplido por ello
nuestros periodistas fueron a los países
para ver cómo trabaja la comunidad para
sacar adelante esta iniciativa ecológica
vital para el planeta en estos momentos
[Música]
los ancianos dicen que la región del
hogar fue una vez verde hoy en día sólo
llueve unas pocas semanas al año 300
mililitros en promedio estamos en medio
de una zona semiárida en el noreste de
senegal en la ruta de la gran muralla
verde
aquí es donde concentra sus esfuerzos el
equipo de haidar y la liga exministro de
medio ambiente y ecologista convencido
y sin un gran plantel de árbol
soy un gran sembrador de árboles y sobre
todo un apasionado por gestar
poblaciones para impulsar a que actúen
por su bienestar y el del medio ambiente
que le rodea porque todo está
relacionado con
él y el ecologista ha sido nombrado
recientemente para dirigir en la agencia
nacional de reforestación y la gran
muralla verde en un intento de
desempolvar el proyecto que ya tiene 15
años
de semana ha habido muchos seminarios
muchos estudios muchos informes mucho
blablabla y sobre el terreno no hay
nadie
haidar en la lía aplica una fórmula
sencilla ir a encontrarse con la gente
del pueblo en pueblo para convencerles
de la utilidad de plantar árboles o la
vaina van al zoo
como aquí en by agua una comunidad rural
del norte de la región del hogar
el ecologista siempre llevaba valiosos
regalos en sus camiones
guayaquil
antes de plantar lo hay que quitar el
plástico negro tenga cuidado de no
remover la tierra
más de mil plantas se distribuyen en
pocos minutos
limoneros mangos
esta es la innovación de haidar el lalín
desde que asumió el cargo centrarse en
los árboles frutales para involucrar a
la gente
[Música]
es así de sencillo para mí dar a la
gente los árboles que necesitan no
haciendo programas para venir a plantar
árboles que nadie necesita y que
acabarán muriendo porque este árbol que
necesitan lo cuidarán lo amarán lo
regalan y esperarán a que dé frutos
en el pueblo de mayagua los árboles
frutales han desaparecido por completo
del paisaje
por ello la familia ven planta su
limonero con gran entusiasmo
esta pareja de agricultores padres de
siete hijos ha visto cambiar su región
guau logra
mejorar y hoy no hay tantos árboles como
cuando yo era niño en aquella época la
vegetación era densa no estaba tan seco
como hoy
así que estoy muy contento los árboles
son importantes
su valor es inestimable
y las plantas que sembramos hoy tan
fruto toda la familia se beneficiarán
imagínese que compramos un kilo de
limones a 600 francos que desistan
franjas
longás el corazón de la zona
silvopastoral de senegal
a medida que se acerca el invierno la
hierba desaparece del suelo el ganado
errante devora cada pequeño brote
este sobre pastoreo agravado por el
cambio climático explica la
desertificación de la región
para dejar respirar a la naturaleza es
necesario innovar a menor coste estas
vainas son baratas y muy populares entre
el ganado
y después de comer la fruta las semillas
quedarán en el estiércol de los animales
devolviendo los a la tierra después de
la temporada de lluvias podemos tener
árboles la gran muralla verde está
llevando a cabo este experimento en la
zona utilizar el ganado para diseminar
la casierra diana o árbol del desierto
se aclaró que extreman nuestro tour por
la meta es un árbol extremadamente
nutritivo para el ganado lo que permite
que el ganado tenga mucha leche pero es
muy importante porque atrae el nitrógeno
a la superficie de hecho enriquece el
suelo
las vainas de acacia se distribuyen
gratuitamente
esto es un regalo del cielo para guzmán
de 11 años
si a veces los lleva lejos para
conseguir comida
ayudará al ciclo de la naturaleza al
tiempo que se satisfacen las necesidades
de la población
esta es la estrategia de haidar el ali
que aplica la llamada regeneración
natural
encontramos al ecologista en plena
actividad en bowl a una comuna rural de
la región esta vez a bordo de una
curiosa caravana que es el mono que se
come la fruta nos comemos a los montes
ya no hay monos para dispersar la
semilla de la psique los humanos tenemos
que ayudar a la naturaleza sustituir a
los animales para dispersar las semillas
a mano con un tirachinas cientos de
miles volveremos aquí dentro de tres o
cuatro años y ver a muchos pubs
cuando semillas germinarán en el suelo
arenoso haidar el aliño hace una apuesta
el ecologista está probando una técnica
que ha experimentado con éxito en el sur
del país donde las precipitaciones son
de 4 a 5 veces mayores junto a él los
pastores fulani se ofrecieron a
participar en la operación
y me informaron que las plantas se
sembrarían hoy
reuní a mis amigos y conocidos cada uno
trajo su propio caballo participamos
porque esta reserva es muy muy
importante para nosotros este es el
único lugar donde todavía hierba para
nuestros animales
la reserva de 700 hectáreas de terreno
vallado protegido del ganado y la tala
un santuario
la gran muralla verde cuenta en total
con una treintena en senegal
este es uno de los éxitos más visibles
de la agencia liga de la
cuenta pierda se remedia aquí no hay
cobertura herbácea aquí eso es para el
ganado y también crea una sombra en la
tierra la tierra no es azotada por el
sol el cual absorbe el agua y mata a
toda la biodiversidad
lo lleva sobre ella se pudrirá y
alimentará la tierra y la y el año que
viene la cobertura de hierbas será aún
más importante la unco fluyen por todo
soluciones sencillas y mucha
sensibilización será suficiente para que
la gran muralla verde emerja finalmente
de la arena
la primera evaluación oficial del
proyecto es muy clara solo se ha
cumplido el 4 por ciento de los
objetivos de recuperación de tierras
para 2030 en la zona de intervención
estricta 18% si se considera la región
en general
mal gobierno promesas incumplidas de los
donantes las razones aducidas son muchas
en nigeria se han restaurado menos de
5000 hectáreas en 10 años
la desertificación amenaza a más de 40
millones de personas en el norte del
país
deforestación
de certificación deforestación esto ha
sumido a las comunidades en la pobreza y
la pobreza conduce a la migración que a
su vez conduce al conflicto al
conflicto y avala safiya no es uno de
los líderes de la representación
nigeriana del proyecto realiza una
visita sobre el terreno a giga agua en
el límite con níger uno de los pocos
lugares del país donde la agencia puede
operar con normalidad
la inseguridad es un reto no podemos
hacer mucho más que contratar los
servicios de los guardias forestales en
las zonas donde la seguridad es
aceptable pero en las zonas donde la
seguridad es deficiente
suspendemos nuestras intervenciones los
planos presións de a
el equipo llega finalmente a gabás mar y
un pequeño pueblo desde 2018 se está
llevando a cabo una operación de
reforestación
en tres hectáreas una superficie
equivalente a cuatro campos de fútbol
el paisaje se ha transformado
a pesar de las apariencias la mayor
dificultad no es la falta de agua
de calidad agua
rogers world nuestros proyectos sufren
muy a menudo del vandalismo de animales
introducidos intencionadamente un hombre
de vándalos que vienen a destruir
nuestros cultivos y a talar árboles y de
ladrones
e incluso esos alambres de espino que se
ven acá podrían ser fácilmente
derribados y retirados si no tuviéramos
a los guardabosques para vigilar los que
que nuevas y ruidosa fresca
[Música]
en este contexto la gran muralla verde
se ha volcado en la formación
para averiguarlo nos dirigimos al estado
vecino decano la comunidad rural de cada
andan y sufre la desertificación
[Música]
doctor maga giles un líder tradicional
que tiene autoridad sobre ocho pueblos
también es agricultor en la plantación
heredada de su padre una tierra que se
ha empobrecido
considerablemente en las últimas décadas
para mí valen igual cuando era pequeño
me llevaron a este campo y había muchos
árboles y las cosechas de entonces eran
varias veces mayores que las actuales
este campo no estaba de comer a todos
más de 30 personas ahora las cosas han
cambiado los árboles están muertos y
nuestras cosechas son insuficientes para
alimentar a la familia
está buena
mukhtar ha recibido formación durante
tres años en la región
antes de que pueda van a querer
inmobiliaria van en primer lugar nos
enseñaron a cuidar nuestras plantas
tradicionales las que crecen
espontáneamente
luego nos enseñaron a plantar árboles
frutales como estos
nos mostraron cómo se cuidan cuando se
plantan crecen durante el invierno y
devuelven la riqueza del suelo les damos
nada si quiere más comodidad o manera al
ver qué pasa
[Música]
el pueblo tiene ahora su propia
guardería aquí no sólo cultivan mangos
sino también naranjos y palmeras
datileras las plantas crecen gracias al
cuidado de toda la comunidad bajo la
supervisión de mukhtar magazine el
patriarca espera salvar su pueblo
la hermana gran cara el desierto del
sahara avanza sobre nuestra tierra y
muchos de nuestros habitantes han
abandonado el pueblo para ir a las
ciudades de lagos o port harcourt en
busca de dinero sin embargo nuestros
suelos son ricos estoy convencido de
ello desde que era un niño he conocido
el valor de esta tierra si conseguimos
cuidar bien la tierra si conseguimos
arreglarla los extranjeros vendrán a
nosotros y nuestros hijos no se irán a
la gran muralla verde también forma a
las mujeres en el conservador norte
musulmán y rara vez salen del patio
familiar
salud al agua es la primera esposa de un
trabajador agrícola del pueblo
lleva haciendo jabón en casa desde su
formación hace casi un año cada bolsa
vendida le reporta 20 nairas unos pocos
céntimos de euros un negocio muy modesto
pero que marca la diferencia para esta
madre
[Música]
y doy gracias a dios porque mi vida ha
cambiado mucho cuando tengo una pequeña
necesidad puedo resolverla sin
expresarme sin ir a pedir dinero
prestado a alguien cuando me despierto
por la mañana y el padre de mis hijos no
puede darme dinero para el desayuno y
dice que no tiene dinero puedo dárselas
se han formado unas 1500 personas y se
han creado otros tantos puestos de
trabajo esta cifra sigue estando muy
lejos de los 10 millones de empleos
verdes a los que aspira el proyecto en
su conjunto y para llegar a los 100
millones de hectáreas restauradas y 2030
habría que cuadruplicar el ritmo actual
de reforestación estos objetivos parecen
haberse perdido de antemano sin embargo
no es el momento de rendirse el anuncio
el pasado mes de enero de una
financiación internacional de más de 14
mil millones de dólares ha vuelto a
poner la gran muralla verde en la mira
todo el mundo está de acuerdo en que hay
una necesidad urgente de actuar en el
sahel se calcula que 135 millones de
personas dependen de estas tierras
degradadas para su subsistencia
llegamos al final de este episodio de
boleto de vuelta a la gran muralla verde
y recuerde que si quiere ver este y
otros contenidos en español puede
visitar nuestra página web france24
puntocom hasta pronto
[Música]